shall I bloom Oh still warm and it's
been a while well the law of cooling is
a decaying exponential but you need a
measurement on the liquid to get the
heat transfer coefficient don't worry
about the measurement for now find a new
way to think about it alright so forget
the tea entirely what if we thought of
molecules like people yes
moving it impossible speeds bumping into
one another and the amount of pressure
people feel can be understood for how
frequently these bumps happen more
people oh gosh no not necessarily
how big is the room say they're crammed
into a crowded hallway jostling and
bumping late for class
I precious
Mileva are you alright I am now let's
place them in a grand ballroom the same
people no more knoweth only now ten
times the size enough to dance freely
around the room more volume fewer
collisions lower pressure
[Music]
let's write a paper together and what
this isn't and you thought just a new
way of seeing it what if this is the way
to prove the existence of molecules this
is how they fund Olli you and me writing
a paper that could change the world the
probability of chaos huh
not the tide liable shoes but we can
discuss it
[Music]